we got this guys we got this we got this
okay what are we doing you love to see
it
you'd love to see it okay
yep let's go we're going to do this
what's courtney doing
courtney county county
that's right it's just that we
established that last time you just hit
that and then you wait
jackie shouldn't have been on that for
as long as she was that's the first
thing i'm gonna say
four two three seven three
because unless there's another task on
that table of which i am unsure
literally all you have to do is just
like
hit the space bar uh five
seven six four four done
beautiful that could be a stat kill we
don't want to let that happen
okay and i don't have to do this side
okay hello
hello all righty
that happens to be so often i think i'm
dead um
i have i have good news for you because
i was trailing you the whole
map and i can say with
quite a bit of certainty you did not
kill spencer i can also say with a lot
of certainty that
damian did not kill spencer because we
just walked up on spencer's body
together in cafeteria
interesting that oh that's nice who'd
you see
literally nobody honestly
i haven't shane in a while no
information
[Laughter]
oh yeah uh i've been with courtney and
ian i saw ian scan i saw ian do a med
scan
and so i followed him around a lot and
then shane was with us
uh at the end there i was a little
scared not gonna lie but i think he was
still figuring out the test so what
we're saying is it's garrett
what he does
what have you been doing i was i
actually went up to
uh fix o2 but damien was there he fixed
it
where were you coming in i went down to
the laboratory i was uh
i was coming from like the laboratory
area
laboratory area is it laboratory no
isn't that
the cafeteria is here yeah like you're
the place where you killed spencer
sarah courtney
yeah i'm gonna skip too yeah i can also
just real quick just to get the info out
there
i can more or less vouch for jackie
because i was doing my upload thing and
she came in
and i think was hesitant of me and then
like yeah for like the whole time
and didn't murder me okay then when i
left the room she went out to go do
whatever she has there so
everyone is vouched for guys i don't
think there's any imposters i think we
can go so weird
goodbye oh my god all right cool
good job we did great everyone stay
alive we're doing good
wait wait guys guys there was an
imposter he killed me
um okay i know nothing except that i
guess ian has been cleared
and spencer was cleared but that doesn't
help you that could be a1
oh thank you i don't really want to be
alone in here
here's the problem shane what are you
doing courtney we cool
courtney are we chilling i think she
would have murdered me
if it were courtney if there's a dead
body in here courtney are you okay
she doesn't know how to do that task
garrett am i supposed to hit
oh the watering can it just moved what
moves every time
oh my god okay
no i don't trust damian i don't trust
damian okay
i have to [ __ ] go there anyway can i
have a buddy hmm
i hate this map so much i hate this map
yeah
i don't know where anything is uh
who just walked out was it jack
i mean yeah because i saw yeah yeah
because coordinates saw you run to the
uh the thingamajig
to stop it and i was like okay so these
guys got it it was the reactor in
reactor so i was walking out why
was it dead because um when i walked up
there up
north there was a dead body i did not
even see that
guys i think it's courtney this is why
okay they're like
here i want here i was running down
you know doing going down the you can't
see my hand it was going down
[Laughter]
down the video it's going to the left
right and the corner of my
eye i see courtney like pop up like in
this like weird like
black part of my screen and so i was
like what they go
over there and then i see courtney
running the other way
so alana saw you know what i'm saying
like i'm pretty sure she vented
where are we going i'm gonna say like i
was watching a lot of weird maneuvers
from courtney
she turned away from the reactor
decontamination room when
there was a meltdown happening i noticed
that that was because i
thought i thought it was in another room
and then she went in
afterwards yeah
please let me defend courtney i have
information to defend courtney
she's i've been with you i'm trying to
help you're gonna vouch for me courtney
was
i can't she was in the cafeteria whether
you were jack
it's not courtney i don't know this map
either
i literally thought i was going up to
the other reactor thing that's why
i'm trying it's not courtney it's not
courtney it's not courtney
it's not courtney okay courtney and i
were in cafeteria together and she was
doing the task where you have to do the
you have to press the the buttons to get
the drinks out and i was like that's
taking her a really long time
and then i realized
we were alone there for so long she
would have killed me she clearly just
didn't know how to do the task
i'm so certain i was watching someone be
a bad uh bad crewmate
i'm so sure she would have [ __ ]
murdered me
either her or it's jack it's either
she would have killed me
oh my god she was just a bad crewmate it
was not her
[ __ ] girl i really
she would have [ __ ] killed me for
sure oh my god
that sucked i don't like it at all
there's no way that she would have seen
me and been standing there and walked
around and not [ __ ] killed me
no way so it's not
ian or jackie i think shane agreeing
with me
and everything that's happening right
now
probably clears shane i think maybe
garrett
because i feel like he's been alone a
lot
oh buddy oh buddy oh
oh garrett just committed a crime gary
just killed your boy big jungus
all right i was running out of there i
had
come out and i missed it and i ran back
and report tried to report it but you
guys no no
no no no it doesn't work that way
because i saw the animation it wasn't
you standing next to a dead body
like i saw you cut them in half so
no this the like the pixels on your
screen
just you showed blood for no reason
while you were standing there i don't
think that's what happened
a huge bummer well no
you know so i i think i'm gonna side the
lana on this one because i alana had a
lot of opportunities to kill me
um um so what i'm going to say is to my
crewmates i think the other one is
damien um
jackie i watched her finish the exact
same task as me we both had the like
spacebar task at the start and when she
finished it the taskbar meter went up
um and then shane siding with me on on
courtney and seemingly doing task two i
think the next one's named yeah but he
sided with you on courtney
well after everybody he has also thrown
her under the bus before so it could be
shane or damien but
it is not 100 not me i i was with damian
in a room the two of us for a second
story just the two of us if i wanted to
that's the perfect place
and if i would have killed you that
would have been the perfect place um
that's how you would think as the
murderess i think it's shane
wait is this the one where i think it's
a lot of me
yes i did vouch for you garrett are you
throwing me under the bus right now
no i think it's alana because i don't
think it's damien
well okay hold on so everybody vote for
gary she was defending no she was
defending courtney
yeah because courtney didn't do it so
strong yeah exactly
her teammate okay but gary i just
watched you cut someone in half
and then say you doubled back i saw the
animation their blood is still within
the blood
i'm willing to go along with easy to say
that you saw
animation that's it i watched the whole
thing say that you sliced in half
a minute of it i saw you filming why
didn't you bring that up earlier then
garrett that sounds a bit strange
what why wasn't that mentioned earlier
guy i'll be playing this game again
this is the game we're playing again
[ __ ] ian one of us is gonna die
in in in oh no
okay okay um zero seven three
nine one check
i think we know what we have to do ian i
think we know what we have to do where
is shane though that is a good question
oh david come on now you i mean i
appreciate that you tried
delilah did i know david is that what
happened did you do it
did you do it
did you just recognize that you were
screwed into a corner that he and i had
both finished our toss and that you were
like well maybe i'll kill you and play
milana right in front of her
yeah so we were right exactly how a
killer would think
yeah yeah you want you weren't playing
it that safe but come on now
okay all right so anyway damian killed
ian who was med base kid a truly
devastating loss
um it's not shane or jackie
the problem is i had opportunities with
both of them
where they could have
i would not have vouched for for jackie
or ian
or courtney so hard i'm so confident
these people
and shane the only reason i couldn't
vouch for you is that i hadn't seen you
very much
it was between you and damian it's
[ __ ] damien you just killed someone
in front of me
i witnessed i'll be honest i i think
it's my gut says damian if it's not
damien alana has played
a perfect queen's gambit i i would love
to
love that but i didn't if i'm the
imposter and garrett
was my partner and garrett just killed
in front of alana
wouldn't it be a bat crap insane move
for me to then
also kill directly in front of alana
yeah
yeah you were trying to do backdrop
insane because you didn't know what else
to
damian explain your side what did you
see we were just coming out from comms
we were all three together inching
around
because clearly we didn't want to be had
to be
and we were just sort of all slightly
moving alana hung back then she went
forward a little bit
and then she kills ian right in front of
me i report first and it's like
no buddy i'm sorry you just killed him
in cold [ __ ] blood
jackie i like i said i vouched for you
because i watched you finish a task and
the toss meter went up at the same time
you and i were alone in a room together
when you did that and then damien walked
in and we both left
jackie we gotta decide jackie we gotta
go just kill me you just [ __ ] killed
me
it's 100 names for you i vowed
to alana if she's got it it's
[Music]
i can't believe you almost got away with
that that was super ballsy all right so
wait what the hell happened
because because it was it wasn't jack
and it wasn't corny in that one kill
who killed that person there was another
i think
it was me then i invented it then i bent
it was only i thought it was either you
or jack i'm so sorry
i was mad at you jackie as i am ian
because
literally i was with
i was watching ian as a ghost and it did
look like
it all happened so fast that i was like
yeah i think it might have been courtney
because you did also like double back at
one point
when the reactor was going off ian's a
wild card because
ian i've never seen he has the most
conviction on vibe checks he'll just
yeah i don't like him okay for sure it's
them
it was just like because we were we were
all hanging none of us know the map
and no one seemed to trust me for not
knowing the map
well i i i i don't think i've seen you i
got so mad
i don't think i've seen you like run up
and report something go
did you see what just happened i was
like
i'm sorry i will forever be salty for
that round but i blame nobody
hey i defended you i defended you based
on thinking you were really bad at the
vending machine task
but you were clearly doing it i was like
she's 100 doing it
i got to the sorting the sorting boxes
and i was like you know what i'm just
not gonna do this one